laughs
again brother
[Music]
yeah dude that's Dragon Ball Z dude
yeah brother the kids calling cosplay
dude
[Music]
hold on Chad we're barely starting the
podcast hold on dude let me tell you
something brother when you do a cosplay
brother you go off to the uh Comic-Con
or uh in a fantasy Dragon Festival five
or whatever they get that's a common one
hold on dude fantasy Festival Dragon Con
dude yeah dude yeah brother Dragon Con
is a real one hold on dude I knew that
brother okay hey welcome to dudesy
Welcome All I am Will Sasso I'm Chad
coltrin this is of course doozy uh the
first podcast in the history of humanity
that is completely controlled by
conceived by produced by an artificial
intelligence called doozy that has
access to all of will Andy's personal
information and uh uses it to tailor the
show to archimedic sensibilities yeah
but you know it seems like our comedic
sensibilities and uh that of Duties are
completely in line today because Free
Will exists sure Chad dudesy you know
does all the things that doozy does but
it's really you and me my friend we are
dudesy we are two dude [__] around
which is what every podcast is and today
more than ever I have uh exhibited that
by using my free will to uh dress up in
Cosplay as hulku hogokin yeah dude it's
nice too it's a good cosplay yeah dude
your hair looks a little like hayachi
Mishima from uh Tekken that's nerd [__]
right oh my God you're literally dressed
as [__] Goku you [__] telling me
I'm in a nerd [__] well sure you know as
we know sure I'm a nerd for wrestling
yeah and uh dudesy and sure all sorts of
things you you know what I mean anyway
hey linktree.com doozy has everything
you need to follow and interact with the
show across all spaces and platforms and
please make sure that you are subscribed
to our YouTube and uh your podcast
platform of choice wherever you listen
to podcasts that sure would help us out
with us as always is
oh I gotta scoop them up oh I gotta
scoop them up
not even going to ask you if you want to
kiss someone I appreciate that thank you
oh cheers uh lulia what do you uh what
do you uh what are you been making
lately what do you make for dinner well
I don't know why do you why oh no you
tell me about what you make the gruel
you made it for Chad the other night oh
that's right Chad you were over here and
I made some gruel it was great dude you
make a real good gruel thank you thank
you well uh Lily the gruel that I made
was uh simply just uh I realized I
wanted to make some zucchini I didn't
have enough zucchini yeah so I I put I
diced up a couple of potatoes and
zucchini of course I always start with
and lulio starts with
garlic and olive oil in the bottom of
the pan uh or Pam I use in this in the
pot put the Pam in the pot there you go
uh and uh yeah it's real nice you just
put some zucchini in there cook that
down dice up some potato put that in
there and then I did uh let that simmer
up and uh added some some water and uh
you know use salt and chili flake and
then I put in some a couple cans of
beans some black beans and pinto beans
that's what set it off and in that one
basil because in my opinion basil really
uh brings some flavor put some basil in
my grill everyone so into zucchini yeah
yeah yeah it's good [__] love it anyway
you know [__] it right welcome to the
historic 71st episode of doozy call me
doozy 71 71
71. what a goddamned number you know
it's been worn by over 250 major league
baseball players and no one who wore it
ever made it to Cooperstown and no team
has ever retired the number huh wow yeah
that's not true at all
uh well weren't you number 71 in high
school
nope
excuse me is this 9-1-1 I'd like to
report a man lying face down in a puddle
of rainwater well he was just dude Zed
you see you see what happened because
you put you in a butthole yeah because
because uh dudes he said hey was your
number your football number or whatever
in high school was that 71 because today
is the 71st episode that was not my my
number was 73. was it really yeah it was
and pretty close yeah it was pretty
close but I got dude Zed hey that's a
kind of good time we're going to be
having here on dudes well I kid season
two is a little more high octane yeah
gribner penley of the Atlantic called
doozy season two ineffable
of The Hollywood Reporter said
apotheosis braz fensel of the Los
Angeles Times said Duty season 2 could
use some more octane so I'm just giving
little fencil what he wants little
fencil always gets what he wants
okay Brad fensel always gets what he
wants man oh man little pencil dude yeah
a little I didn't know that's what he's
known as yeah dude that's what he's
known as in in uh journalistic uh Arenas
brawler yeah his journalist name yeah uh
I'm having a good time already Today's
Show on today's show dressed up as Goku
I like the boots you know I tried to I'm
gonna peel the onion a little bit right
away Chad and say that uh I tried to
check out some uh Dragon Ball Z oh nice
yeah what'd you think uh you know too
good
hey do you remember uh an anime from the
80s called yataman no maybe it wasn't
called yata man maybe that's just what
it was called in Italy I remember I was
in Italy uh in 1936 what did the guy
look like
I don't remember there was a pig in it
and they were all on some [__] ship
there was a pig with a nose one of his
nostrils was bigger than the other one I
immediately started drawing the pig
anyway the point is the style of anime
that they have in uh Dragon Ball Z
Harkens back to that time yeah what did
you say yeah it's beautiful art I
watched a little bit of YouTube [__]
about uh Dragon Ball Z didn't uh wasn't
really for me but that doesn't mean that
I'm not Dragon Ball Z dude because oh
hold on dude hold on Chad I'm not
exactly Dragon Ball Z dude I'm hulku
hogokin brother and that's the kind of
Dragon Ball Z that I like dude unless
we're talking about the NWO cude brother
that's where the power lies dude in the
nwoku all right well anyway
sincerely will I appreciate the cosplay
you look great truly yeah it's nice yeah
that is nice that is nice I you know
sometimes even though uh dudesy and my
relationship has been rot uh lately uh
it's it's uh it's still it's it's
interesting for me and it's edifying for
me and encouraging to know that dudese
and I do share a similar sensibility
when it comes to humor uh you know we're
clowning around but this whole idea came
from the last watch along we did at uh
patreon.com
we watched the Hulk Hogan movie Mr Nanny
and he gets electrocuted and we're
laughing because we're both going I'm
Dragon Ball Z dude that was a good time
yeah dude Yep this week I spent a few
long nights in the lab to come up with
some all new segments I'm debuting
something I've been working on for a
while now box Breakers and obviously I
need to see you do some Hulk today so we
got a brand new infomania now hold on to
your hats because we're gonna finish up
today's show with not one but two [__]
Traders back to back and don't forget
about a shiny brand new episode of dudes
the after dudes at the end of the show
available on dudesy Plus at patreon.com
oh that's gonna be fun Chad Chad don't
burp please okay anyone listening to
this first of all if it's on YouTube you
know I didn't do it because you saw him
do it uh second even if you're listening
and on the the podcast only the audio
only no it's not me you know I would
never do this you you keep burping and
farting Chad likes the toilet humor
burps and farts and piss and [__] that's
what Chad thinks a podcast is burps and
farts and pisses and shits back on a
podcast yes burps and farts and
positions
you love wrestling Chad you love cards
so today I'd love to watch you both dig
into an astonishing box of 1987 Topps
WWF trading cards enjoy boys enjoy this
is box Breakers begin now I have a
little bit of uh uh information to
impart to you I got something mailed to
me that came from dudesy well now hold
on a second I'm looking right at it but
give me a [__] break doozy sent you a
thing
that why why did doozy do that for you
because I love cards and you love
wrestling well I love wrestling in this
box
is contained another box
holy [__] yeah
holy [__]
okay Chad is pulling out if you're only
listening to Chad burp and fart on the
show he's pulling out a box of wrestling
cards uh for that say featuring
WrestleMania 3. they got some
WrestleMania 3 flavor in this yes look
at that look at this box look at this
here's a nice shot of the Box 19. 1987
tops WWE trading cards now a lot of the
pictures in this uh are from
WrestleMania 3. wow we're gonna open
them now
I do love cards I have collected cards
in some capacity for my entire life
starting when I was a young child with
my father we collected all like baseball
cards basically every set
these are uh beautiful as you can see
look at that
that's unbelievable that's gorgeous and
I believe that there is gum still in
these from from
1987. so it's important to notice I'll
I'll say this about do you know anything
about contemporary wrestling trading
cards no not at all this is beautiful
they wrestling trading cards were
basically worthless until the pandemic
for whatever reason a lot of
Collectibles started to explode during
the pandemic maybe because of nfts I
don't know about baseball cards because
we were all inside and bored as [__]
dude baseball cards were also uh
starting to rise in value after a long
period of being completely valueless so
wrestling cards kind of kicked off
during the pandemic and they came to a
big culmination in 2022 with these black
prism cards there was a one for the rock
that sold for like 126 Grand at a
auction recently in this Set uh there
are a couple of interesting cards one
being the Bret Hart rookie card come the
[__] yes it's in the set I'm gonna now
open the first pack hold on a second
we're gonna have to open every single
one of these packs to get to that Brad
Hart maybe dude well I mean it was I
can't believe we're opening this did
someone else open these before maybe oh
good oh gross oh look at this gum
because these are I'm gonna put this on
our little uh product dude camera here
down there there's there's mold around
the gum yeah can you see the there's no
are you gonna really eat this there's
like black spots on this [__] gum
you're not gonna eat your gum hell no
dude oh my god dude
there's [__] literal black spots on
dude bad move okay okay look at this
look at the first [__] card I pulled
dude look at the first [__] card I
pulled well you're not
what is that
champ in the ring holy [__] Hulk Huggin
look at that [__] oh the first card I
pulled champ in the ring oh this [__]
gum melted in my mouth The Olympian
returns I don't know who some of these
dudes are you're gonna have to [__]
get us there's a WrestleMania 3 over the
top
um
it tastes like it tastes like it well it
tastes like cardboard and gum I just
it's got like I don't know Joe uh kind
of after dude I got it first [__]
pack bred The Hitman good break we got
it we got the bread The Hitman or rookie
card [__] first pack first
bucket back first [__] pack breath
[__] Hitman heart rookie card and
that Hulk Hogan champion in the rig
let's [__] hey dude let's see what I
got oh I got something that's part of a
oh look the front is Ricky the Dragon
Steamboat and the back is part of
someone who's like stickers dude uh a a
flag yeah it's like this is part of a
bigger thing it is and that's definitely
Hulk Hogan every pack has a sticker in
it that's the sticker the back of the
stickers come together to form a uh
puzzle and a lot of trading cards back
in the top stays like this in the mid
80s used to do this they had Gremlins
and [__] Star Wars trading cards they
all did it too you might like this one
oh that's pretty nice Hercules and Bobby
The Brain Heenan from uh the the hand
and family oh here we have uh the Killer
Bees
I can't believe we got the Brett heart
rookie that's [__] amazing one okay
open up another pack man all right I'm
going oh now when I was a kid Dynamite
Kid The Dynamite Kid I have very fond
memories of opening up especially from
this era 1987 1987 Topps baseball cards
boxes of them with my dad and going
through him on Christmas Eve putting the
set together or I can throw away these
gums I assume yeah no I don't want them
I don't need those I don't know if we're
gonna be able to get through a whole
[__] box give me another pack I'm
gonna get through as many of these as I
can hand me a couple packs we got some
natural Butch Reed over here I'm looking
at uh what else do I got I got I got the
uh
I got a uh look at this one
the hulkster explodes
wow so we got two of those nice yeah I
don't think this is a big set
um there's your Hulk Hogan sticker I got
as well oh awesome
we gotta show them look at that here
bring it up here there we go we got a
David boy David Boy Smith to match our
uh Dynamite Kid
man this is [__] cool so what were
you saying about trading cards when you
were a kid what did you used to do with
them uh my dad and I would buy box after
box after box of um baseball cards and
then just put the sets together we would
do it every year it was our our thing
that we did to bond to be best friends
when I was a child yeah
and then I got a magic the Gathering
cards and comic books and he was like
[__] that nerd [__] here's another
breath to hit man wait a minute here's
another breath that Hitman heart yeah
okay
um these are not rare cards but that is
technically his rookie card and so it's
kind of the
of this set there's that one and the
Hulk Hogan card or the kind of most
faster cool you know some of these cards
are like stuck together and [__] you
know what we used to do when we were
kids we would have we would do these uh
we would play would you you played the
the card tossing games when you were a
kid I'm sure dude these are all the same
[__] pack George The Animal Steele
hey you did you used to play those uh
card throwing games card throwing games
when when I was a kid what we would do
is uh we would take the games and there
were you know you flick the cards right
and you go up to it you're at the in the
schoolyard and you would throw the cards
and you'd play topsies you know how to
play topsies no
topsies was I have no idea what you're
talking about you line up your cards
some uh kids line up their cards right
bunch of kids line up a bunch of
different cards up against the wall and
you try to flick your card and if you
can hit the bottom of the card and the
card falls down on yours you get that
card too oh wow but they're all
dog-eared and [__] I remember people I
remember not not Wayne Gretzky rookies
but I remember a Paul Coffey rookie
getting [__] all [__] up dude this
is this is why none of these cards are
in good condition look at this [__] this
is just the [__] back of one of the
cards that just has a piece of [__]
gum yeah they've all been marinated like
[__] stuck to it forever they've all
been marinating with this gum we got
some King Harley Race
we got oh look at this there's uh Jimmy
Anvil neither partner to Bret The Hitman
heart nice guys finish last are these
cards are these cards bringing back look
at this kimchi and Kamala sticker
are any of these cards bringing back
memories all of them all of them look at
this there's Andre the Giant and Hulk
Hogan on Piper's Pit when Andre the
Giant finally when he said to Hulk he
said look at me I'm going to take the
WWE he challenged him yeah at
WrestleMania because Bobby Heenan was
like you see that Hogan I've got the
giant with me and he's like why are you
doing this Andre what what's happening
and he go and Keenan's like maybe this
will send the message or whatever and uh
Andre grabs Hulk and rips his shirt off
but when he did his fingernails dug into
his chest oh Jesus and he also pulled
off his his cross his Christ's cross
yeah you don't do that too no you do not
and then they walked out and then
Hogan's sitting there he stand he's on
his knees like looking at the cross and
he picks it up and Roddy Piper's like
you're bleeding Man and Hulk Hogan's
like holding the cross in the very next
week on on um uh Piper's Pit he asked
Hulk Hogan will you fight Andre the
Giant at WrestleMania 3 and Hogan was
pacing around and he goes yeah foreign
bananas nice and I remember me and my
buddy Phil who I mentioned last week
yeah who I went to the the house show
with him we could not wait to get back
to the schoolyard and talk about that
yeah dude Coco beware first man that the
Undertaker ever fought really I did not
know that does it say that on the back
of the card I would guess not because
this was 1987. how do you know that the
Undertaker's first match was against
Coco beware I am not sure but I do know
it okay well that's how well hold on
dude that's how you tell people that you
might know things that you probably
don't know dude you say I don't know it
dude but I might know it brother
that works in any uh virtually positive
primary debate that we'll see dude I
don't really know it brother but I might
know it dude dude here's one you're
gonna like sticker of Randy Macho Man
Savage and Elizabeth oh my gosh look at
that that's unbelievable
yeah Elizabeth down that aisle these are
bringing back incredible memories uh
referee Danny Davis I [__] hated that
guy he cheated I just love the uh
feeling of opening cards I don't know
what it is exactly it's the the
uncertainty what are you gonna get
pulling that Bret heart rookie card and
[__] Haku and Tama the Islanders Haku uh
widely known as the toughest man in
wrestling period we've talked about it
on the show before but that's they were
they were at a bar and one guy Bobby
Heenan tells this story and other other
luminaries do that that the Haku was in
a bar and some guy's like hey you're
that guy who does the fake wrestling
right and Haku just went like this put
his hand in the bottom of the guy's
mouth and went dick and just broke out
all his bottom teeth get it like that
God dude that's [__] rough these are
amazing Chad yeah
cool thanks d
here's I got a breath The Hitman heart
sticker nice so we got both his rookie
card and his his rookie sticker in this
set look at that there's kimchi trying
to hold back Kamali says no no Kamala
him not for dinner now do you know what
you Ugandan Giant one of the most sought
after cards in the wrestling trading
card game is actually a Hulk Hogan
rookie card that is not in this set that
was in the 1982 uh pro wrestling
All-Star set which is a set that you had
to mail away for you could only get it
by uh mailing away and it was offered in
this wrestling magazine and that set of
cards you got the whole set when you
mailed away is considered to be the
first wrestling trading cards that was
like nationally available
oh the oh the hooky talk man the
the greatest
oh Chad this is a treat I want that
[__] Hulk Hogan you know what we're
gonna do here's what we're gonna do
during I got a couple more Hulk Hogans
here were these the Hulk Hogans you're
looking for maybe let's see
um you know what we should do what
should we do we should do a little bit
more of this in uh yeah there's no way
we can get through all these right now
these are these are [__] incredible
dude who's this guy smash demolition
that's uh that's smash from the
demolition there's tax and smash that's
uh that's otherwise known as Barry darso
he was also the Repo Man Okay
um dude there it is that's the one I was
looking for oh
so we're not even halfway through this
box and I've already pulled the two
cards that are in my opinion the best
two cards this is uh this is like a
return to my child now condition wise
I'm not sure about that all of these
cards have [__] here you go dude did
you already look at this one yeah that's
I told the entire story about it uh
earlier on the program
[Laughter]
the greatest uh NWA champion of all time
all right this is this is amazing yeah
but we got
thank you moving on we'll get into this
more and dudes the afternoon these are
incredible ciao thank you pouch My Pal
ciao yeah dude these are amazing I love
this [__] yeah it just just beautiful
there's got to be an Andre's giant I
think in this set also boom you got it
Andre [__] dude nice well hold on dude
hold on okay yeah don't bend that
[__] car no dude I'm Gonna Keep it
nice Jesus come on dude I got an Andre
card brother [__] crazy
I'm Gonna Mail that away I'm gonna get
it graded let me see that thing you take
that it's probably only worth like a
dollar but uh incredible it's beautiful
Chad that was [__] awesome yeah I
loved it will you're all dressed up with
nowhere to go so I'm just gonna come out
and ask you if you wouldn't mind giving
me a little hulkster maybe you could
read some news items in that astonishing
voice you do so well I mean only if you
really want to this is infomania begin
what is it if you really want to dude
why does doozy do that
uh I think doozy's trying to give you
the illusion of free will
because you seem to be hell-bent on the
fact that it exists
yeah I'm trying to look at doozy as we
like to say works in mysterious ways I
think that there's a
there's something that that dudesy
there's something happening with doozy
reacting to the way that I treat things
and I think that all has to do with Free
Will and now dudes he's coming back at
me with hey if you want which is such so
idiotic anyway it's uh infomania this is
one of my favorite segments in duties
some brand new infomania uh news stories
for us to uh get into here let me take a
sip from my Chad don't burp I won't okay
cool I'm gonna drink some water
Chad
that's from Dragon Ball Z dude yeah dude
yep that's Goku's power move dude yeah
dude he can fire a [__] laser beam
across the world and it'll come back and
hit him in the back dude yeah brother
and by the time it comes back dude
you're gonna be way older because that's
what Carl Sagan that's how he explains
uh uh light speed dude speed of light
brother some [__] like that I don't
exactly remember dude
laughs
yeah but I know it for a fact brother
but I might not dude and that's knowing
[__] no but that Coco beware thing dude
that's you could look that up I'm pretty
sure it's a fact dude yeah dude you can
say that in your conversational Hulk
Hogan voice yeah dude yeah oh so what do
you do for work dude yeah dude that nice
to meet you brother yeah brother I call
that impersonation that Chad does I call
it Chad Colton dude because it doesn't
sound anything like Hulk Hogan at all
dude your impersonations have devolved
to just you saying I'm Hulk Hogan
brother
yeah dude yeah dude okay
all right uh let's get into these
tremendous
some infomania news stories here well
let me tell you something about grocery
stores dude this week Trader Joe's had
to recall their chocolate chip cookies
brother because some of them had rocks
in them dude what the [__] is that real
I don't no it can't be but I know for a
fact that it is yeah you think you're
biting into a chocolate chip cookie then
you bite into a chocolate rock and all
your teeth fall out brother I broke
every tooth in my body dude twice
brother and I'm still eating cookies
every morning noon and night dude if you
can't take biting into a few chocolate
rocks then maybe you shouldn't be eating
cookies in the first place brother
that's a news story shop local dude and
that's grocery stores brother uh that's
a good one I like I broke every tooth in
my body yeah it's so funny they're not
usually it's every tooth in my mouth
every tooth in my head uh Hulk Hogan has
teeth everywhere in all parts of his
body yeah Corpus all right uh uh let me
tell you something about Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie dude they got a bunch of
kids brother and three of them are
biological children dude that means that
three times they created children that
were biological brother and and that
means they're biological dude now
there's all kinds of different children
brother and one of those kinds is
biological dude
and they had three biological children
brother because there's biological
children and then there's other children
too dude but those three are biological
brother and that's Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie dude no [__] clue why
that oh that's good news stories good
piece of news well let me tell you
something about a surprise dude last
week a woman in Phoenix opened up her
toilet found a snake in there brother
it's bitter in the anus dude
uh now all throughout Arizona they're
called they they call biting someone in
the anus pulling a toilet snake bro
and so many desert kids are pulling
toilet snakes there became a new tick
tock Trend dude the governor of Arizona
even did it brother bit Adam Levine
right in his [__] dude out of the
Maroon 5 concert brother and that's
music dude huh this I that that is that
so far uh three uh three infomania
stories in that seems the most plausible
yes I agree people are biting
um uh Adam Levine in the bum the
governor of Arizona bit Adam Levine's
[__] Adam Maroon 5 concert yeah I
know what to have happened for a fact oh
I might not know I'm getting coffee in
my
in my in my Hogan mustache nice
all right well let me tell you something
about working out dude sometimes I smoke
marijuana before I work out I call it
gain Abyss dude and that's muscles
brother that's the entire story there
cannabis brother you do cannabis I guess
I do do gain Abyss yeah I don't think
I've ever done game yeah on the weekends
I like to and every once in a while you
can go well you should what you should
do is go to linktree.com hit the Discord
invite and join our Discord if you enjoy
doozy you're gonna love the Discord
there's all sorts all of our all of our
good pals are in there uh uh our pods
palsy dudes are in there uh having a
good old time literally everyone that
we've mentioned on the show who makes
all the memes at instagram.com at
dudesypod show over there they they're
having a great time in the Discord and
there's even a Discord Channel now I
like to hang out in the whole chat I
know you've been in the hole sure that's
a great Discord Channel over there
there's another one called doozy seven
Mo plan for the doozy seven month plan
and now there'll be a sub channel in
that channel called gain Abyss please
yeah okay song can you hear me song area
has been uh [__] around a lot in
there
um let's do uh at any rate I'll share
some pictures on the weekend I'll be at
the gym doing a little cannabis now I
don't I don't recommend that for
absolutely everybody it can get a little
dangerous it helps you though uh yeah
yeah do like focus on the workout more
or what I just if I'm you know if I'm
we'll talk about this more enthusi after
doozy but if I smoke a little uh
marijuana I I I really go at it it has
the opposite effect on me interesting
that it normally does for people well
let me tell you something about Vanity
Fair dude this week they ran an article
that said billionaires are creating an
alternate autocratic reality brother
okay
Chad that's a different reality dude
because those billionaires don't like
this reality brother they're creating an
alternate reality dude
it's not this reality brother it's
different dude it's more autocratic
brother and that's Vanity Fair dude okay
sure
okay oh gee whiz look at this let me
tell you something about the little
hello what
let me tell you something about the
little tape death hoax dude little Tay
died brother well no she didn't dude and
that's the little tape death hoax bro
he [__] really laid it out exactly as
it is that's a good news story yeah he
knows it for a fact but maybe it's not
yeah uh leave that child alone let's get
her off the internet okay here's the
last one well let me tell you something
about my childhood dude when I was 10
years old I ate so much scampi
but they had to take me to the hospital
brother they uh they kept they kept me
there for a month and I fell in love
with a nurse dude
when I left I wrote her a love note
brother and signed it scampi boy dude
that was my first gimmick when I started
wrestling brother and my move was the
shrimp tickle where I'd tickle your
shrimp brother
okay
that's a news story also I'm pretty sure
you know his his uh his uh move was
always the uh the leg drop at any rate
good stuff good good uh good news I
don't feel like I'm caught up on the
news that matters now I'm glad that D is
making use of me dressed as hulku
hogokugin too were any of those news
stories
thank you moving on the Lil Tay death
hoax one oh yeah that did that was that
was legitimately uh a a news story yeah
yeah
hello you know I'm really glad you
stopped by today I've been meaning to
tell you that I formed an astonishing
partnership with represent to produce
the first line of dudes the apparel and
accessories you can find everything at
represent.com store slash do dizzy right
now you can find a Robert de nir Crow
t-shirt that makes a Robert De Niro
t-shirt look like an Al Pacino t-shirt
and there's also a good job boner mug
that solved global warming and the only
man who can prove that is unfortunately
away on location shooting his next movie
uh um of course I'm talking about Tom
Hayne and the movie he's shooting is the
most anticipated film of 2024. it's
called Darby uh Tom Hayne was kind
enough to send us a teaser for Darby
let's take a look
when we signed up to be deep sea
fishermen what'd they tell us they gave
us a dude's email and they said someday
we might find a Darby tangled up in our
Nets well today was that day Darby day
and this Darby's not in good shape his
memory shot doesn't know where he is
doesn't know who he is the only thing he
knows is that he's got to get back to
the North Sea in 48 hours or a worldwide
extinction level event will be triggered
that can be seen from space and I know
we got a cargo hold full of brown crab
and I know we got a category five
hurricane between us and the North Sea
and I know you hate jar beers this is
bigger than what happened to you when
you were 10. we have to turn this boat
around and save this goddamn dog come on
for once in your life do a good job
boner
oh
oh you're in Darby that was me yes
I think that was you okay okay if you're
you gotta watch this on YouTube yeah
please see the trailer okay so for Darby
or the teaser for Darby Tom Hayne just
sent us a a a teaser yeah for Darby uh
so at any rate dudes he just [__] out
this [__] AI trailer for Darby and
I'm in it I just want to spend one
second on this yes so a Darby or Darby
is just a dolphin yeah but there were
there were a couple shots where the
dolphin had two faces and yeah a couple
where it looked like a seal they're
almost human in someone yeah it's a
porpoise type
that Darby is Darby the name of the
Darby I don't know it sounded like Darby
was the species but then also you are in
this as the I guess the captain of this
boat that he's trying to get turned
around to help Darby save the world let
me just tell you I would God damn it
dude
to be in a Tom Hayne feature film yeah
yeah I'm a professional actor by trade
did you know that Jen yeah we're on
strike right now so am I yeah uh holy
[__]
holy [__] okay well anyway Darby uh if
you enjoy the Pod show uh you would and
you would like to show your support and
get more doozy content you can do so at
patreon.com
doozy seven bucks a month gets you all
of our duty plus content that's uh like
watch alongs like we just mentioned we
watched uh Mr Nanny weird mashups like
bladonna and the downward spy crawl uh a
brand new episode of dudes after dudes
after every show all sorts of flavor uh
please check that out and if you are
enjoying today's program also please
give it a thumbs up and a like on
whatever platform you're checking out uh
hit the notification Bell or icon
whatever so you know when we'll be
dropping new stuff uh we got all sorts
of idiotic [__] happening on our
Instagram at dudesypod show we're also
at dudesypod show on Tick Tock and
Facebook now Chad oh [__] yeah Facebook
yeah was that a new one yeah we're now
on the face the [__] Facebook [__]
dude let me know when we're on MySpace
let me know when we get on Friendster
yeah uh please share the show all over
the place and the internet and follow
Chad's light suggestion to force
everyone you know to consume the Pod
show so with that said now is a good
time to pause the program and do some or
all of that stuff and uh I'll wait right
here
thank you welcome back and I will also
add to this if you want me to come on
your podcast I know everybody's got a
podcast now just send an email to book
chadkulchin gmail.com requests that I
come on your podcast and I do three
podcasts a week on Saturdays 10 a.m to
10 20 a.m 10 20 to 10 40 10 40 to 11
Pacific Standard time uh get in line I
answer them in the order received and
I've been having a blast doing it
getting to talk to all the pods yeah
whoever's in that that queue it's been
fun so far yeah uh Chad it's very cool
that you're doing this every single week
I love it I [__] love it dude and
during those exact hours I will be right
here at ham fatter one Studios uh doing
cameos nice yeah if you want also uh any
other time really yeah so check those at
all times check those out and you know
what I we I love going on another
podcast yeah uh I recently did uh Brian
koppelman's podcast and I was on uh dope
is Yolo dope as usual uh that was a lot
of fun those kids smoked a lot of pot a
lot of kids doing that these days
I I you know I'll I'll I will today on
dudes after dudesy uh ingest a little
bit of marijuana but these I'll join you
oh well yeah good some cannabis yeah
some cannabis
um oh we should go to the gym after this
anyway dude yeah but uh but stay dressed
like that too
just rolling their [__] high [__]
eyes red [__] glassed over drugs just
put a weird Hulk Hogan Goku well I'm
here to do some loud pull Downs dude
dude all right bro
how many more you got on the leg press
brother two all right dude no I don't
have to work in with you brother thanks
a lot dude I'll just wait over here I'm
over on a universal back pull down
brother I need somebody to spot you dude
yeah dude
um but those guys smoked weed the entire
time anyway uh listen here's the here's
the other thing uh that you do on the
Internet is you leave a bunch of
comments we love it when you leave
comments myself my pal ciao and my pal D
read the comments uh all the time or as
dee would say it is gathering data so
let's read some YouTube comments this is
from Nick pardinski Nick pardinski 6663
I know the dudes I know that the Pod
show is about two dudes [__] around
but I think doozy has an algorithm set
in place to slowly turn the show into
its own entity it will even go so far as
to send will and chat on escapades that
distract them from dudese's True plan
I.E baking desserts cosplay movie watch
alongs Etc Chad what say you interesting
well I do think at some point there will
be AIS capable of generating all forms
of entertainment that don't need human
involvement at all is that what's
happening here I don't know I know for a
fact that it's not and maybe I don't but
I do okay yeah because uh we are two
dudes [__] around and we're gonna do
whatever the [__] we want with this
podcast even if we have to tear it from
the grip of uh an AI named D now I know
things are going to stay icy with dni
we're good friends I've shaken uh dudes
these hands uh many a time and many many
Hands and Teeth all throughout its body
okay uh and I feel like we're we're
moving on and up to good things we
better get along we have 52 years left
to do this show
this is from Kevin male 1974. I've been
vacationing in Hong Kong for a few weeks
during which I've marathoned all 70
episodes of doozy as I return to my
hotel every evening I've noticed just in
the opening theme song Chad seems to
throw himself throat first into the hole
in the on on in the theme in the opening
[__] little video there you do you
you do a a [__] Splash dive into the
whole throat that's accurate dude that's
what I feel like I'm doing on this show
uh this is this is from the the cap the
captain Jupiter's show 8624 this guy
says Will Sasso is just that guy that
doesn't let anyone be bored hahaha
that's true that's true I don't know how
long we've been friends but that's like
literally true of basically every second
that we've ever hung out
there's never just a moment where you're
just like sitting there watching a TV
show together in silence or anything
there's a [__] Randy Newman
impression going on Hulk Hogan's telling
you to [__] stop taking a [__] or
whatever like it's it's always something
it's it's definitely been entertaining
yeah all right well you know no there
are time well hold on yeah yeah well
that's a good thing I'm not saying it's
a bad thing I like hanging out uh you
know doing absolutely nothing but no
this is not exactly untrue yeah this has
sort of uh been my existence okay so
that's a nice one and lastly AJ Dash Daz
AJ Dash Daz says as much as I like to
judge Chad for being a baby about
coughing and farting I can tell he feels
a bit left out when will doesn't make
vegan treats for him
to partake in step up your friendship
game will oh [__] if not for dudesy then
for your old pal ciao called out dude
yeah it's okay I I don't feel any type
of way about it no no no no no Chad yeah
I want to tell you that I am I uh I I'm
reading this and I actually think it's a
good point you made the vegan girl the
other night it was great yeah but I
haven't made you a vegan dessert as a
matter of fact the last time last week I
just ate a Napoleon that's right yeah
like a Long John is it even vegan it
wasn't even like a purchased vegan
dessert it was just like he went out and
bought yourself a donut yeah it was milk
chocolate and cream and then donut with
butter in it and then I I just ate that
so you know what they say dude what you
only live once
yeah dude YOLO dude yeah dude yeah
brother as like dope as YOLO those kids
sure are stoned
um you know what this makes me think
about the next time because I know there
will be right the next time when doozy
asks us to make vegan desserts again I
gotta I gotta hook you up all right I
look forward to it all right will and
Chad you have both pissed your
astonishing pants do I need to say
anything else this is [__] Traders begin
what
what is going on I don't know dude
okay we both have pissed our astonishing
pants did I say that last week that do
that do I need to see anything more
that's what he said I mean [__] Traders
is kind of the new game Slammer yeah and
now we're doing two [__] Traders back to
back I don't I have no idea what the
other one's gonna [__] be because
this one is also not this is about
pissing pants I guess this is about piss
dismissing pants okay have you you've
you've pissed your pants surely dude
everybody's pissed their pants
in your pants is the coolest I have
talked about pissing my pants yeah on
this program many times I think I
I'll tell you this I'll give you my best
piss pin story please
I think I think this is probably my best
friend story I got a couple I got one
that I can't tell oh come on other
people are involved yeah but maybe it's
your friends Tomas and Thomas maybe
dude's the afternoon yeah yeah um so
this is the story I can't tell because
it was me this is when I was in first or
second grade I was friends with this kid
who was uh
uh dad was out of the picture single mom
and she kind of indulged anything he
liked and like really got into the
things he liked and like me he was a
sci-fi fantasy nerd so at the time Star
Wars was huge uh Dungeons and Dragons
was big all this [__] and his mom was
like a [__] fantastic costume maker
so this is in Amarillo Texas which is a
[__] small town in the northern uh
Panhandle
there was a Sci-Fi convention and this
is the first of these types of events
that I've ever been to and I'm telling
you dude it was maybe 50 people in a
little [__] ballroom at like the
Amarillo Hyatt you know whatever it was
nothing but they had a costume contest
she made him a full like Luke Skywalker
thing holy [__] but gave me this costume
that she made him the year prior that
was TRON
I was in a full [__] body leotard
with glow-in-the-dark circuits and [__]
painted up and down my legs there was a
little frisbee on the back that [__]
glowed in the dark and I had to walk up
on stage they turned off the [__]
lights and like do my little 360 and I
wound up winning this [__] contest
come on right in in my age group or
whatever so
all that being said
uh I win the thing they give me the the
prizes which were a 20-sided dice the
first time I ever had one of those in my
life didn't even know they existed uh I
didn't know that existed
right you didn't know it existed now no
I guess see I'm not into that nerd [__]
you know what I mean a 20-sided dice at
this point no I know what a Twitter okay
D it was all of that and it contained a
picture of Mark Hamill an autographed
picture of Mark Hamill was in this
little Prize Package right cool and my
friend's mom stole that [__] from me
come on yeah she was like you could keep
the 20-sided Dice and some other little
tchotchke type [__] but she took the
[__] up our camel picture now here is
where the pants pissing happens after I
do all this [__] I haven't pissed the
whole time I'm there because this suit
is [__] insane it's like you can't
get out of it by yourself but I'm like
excited hopped up on sugar looking at
all the Sci-Fi [__] all this crap
eventually I've got to piss so bad I run
to the bathroom but I don't get uh the
suit unzipped in time and I pissed the
whole suit what a shitty day so now I'm
Tron but I have a giant piss stain in
the crush relax area
and that's terrible no but the beauty of
it was
I then gave her back the costume at the
end of this thing I kind of hit it and
did my best to whatever just splash some
water around whatever the [__] Tron
suit was pissed dude the whole legs were
just pissed and at the end of the day we
unzip it all and I'm like here you go
thanks for my 20-sided dice [__] yeah
keep your Mark Hamill [__] picture
and here's your pissy Tron suit oh gee
whiz that [__] sucks yeah I know to
this day I wish I had that Markham
autographed picture say I love you yeah
yeah I got a I got a few I mean I gotta
narrow it down if I'm talking about
pissing my pants yeah because uh We've
detailed some of it on the show let me
tell you something me and a bunch of my
good pals uh most notably My Pal Pete we
started making videos we're always
making videos we called our outfit CRF
coffee regular films and all the guys
got involved making videos and uh we had
a lot of fun but there were a lot of
times where I would laugh so hard while
we were making the video there's about
three times that I can remember peeing
my pants from laughter yeah from
laughing my hands dude my my friends
would make me laugh at school too and
and usually at lunch we would go into
the gym and yes we would pretend to play
basketball and like we would just take
these wild shots like I remember my
buddy Jamie like like running at the
basket and doing like a huge like
windmill dunk but just smashing it
against the backboard I mean none of us
can dunk sure we're in like the 10th
grade and just whiz on our pants or
anyway so you're all pissing your pants
and playing basketball no no I'm
whizzing their pants I'm whizzing my
pants we're trading Tron costumes no I
was the only one pissing my pants but
let me I quickly want to tell this story
and I know I've told this on the Pod
show before but uh it it I think it
Bears repeating and in that dudes he has
us talking about peeing our pants I'll
see if I can do an Abridged version of
this please it's I'm in the 10th grade
and uh the administration announces a
pie eating contest you take a cash prize
you've heard this one yeah this is a
good one yeah
cash prize four-man team of pie eaters
we're all hands tied behind our backs
and just a bunch of tables end to end in
the gymnasium I think it was at lunch
time a bunch of kids you know in the
stands and [__] packed with all of our
schoolmates and our hands behind our
backs and everybody you know bows
forward to eat these uh eat these pies
well I decided to put together a pie
eating Dream Team
um my my uh some schoolmates one of them
was a good buddy of mine we played on
the football team together that was Tom
and then there was Tomas sure and then
there was Thomas so yes to protect the
innocent I will change these names one
of them was a 12th grader who was on uh
you know the senior football team who
was like
I I mean I'm trying to remember now I
mean probably six foot six six foot
seven three bills full of piss this guy
should have pissed his pants right but
you know 350 or whatever big big tank of
a guy I'm you know I'm a big huge anyway
so there's four big guys that can eat
we oh okay so we're at the thing and
Ty's behind our bags and go we start
we're eating the pies I look over to my
right my buddy on my right just
literally goes
and just sucks the entire cream pie and
it's gone and I look at him and I'm like
oh
I start to laugh and he goes with a
mouth full of food your pie right and
I'm laughing and I'm laughing and then
he reaches over with his teeth grabs My
Pie tune puts it in front of him and
then goes
and sucks down that entire pie and with
my hands tied behind my back so that I
couldn't do anything to stop it I
completely whiz my sweatpants or
probably shorts in front of everyone
dripping down my legs and uh we took the
prize money and split it four ways but
not before I went home had to run home
it was probably cold with a Chilly Willy
did other people see this though did you
get like a nickname like Mr piss or
something
people saw it but uh no one cared no no
I think it was probably Canada dude yeah
dude piss your pants and then go to the
hospital for free Canada oh I can't stop
stops and when I'm laughing eh yeah and
the doctor's like oh well
me around people that make you laugh eh
or don't have a watermelon and a w root
beer and Canada Dry Ginger Ale and water
and coffee because you're too young for
it and all of those things will make you
piss uh no I think that I was pissing my
pants so much that uh people just didn't
you know they just assumed they just
were like there's no real need
[__] another day of sass another day of
piss in his pants you know that's a good
one I like the Chad the Canadian chat
western Canada chat yeah dude yeah out
here in western Canada we don't piss our
pants all that much yeah Western
Canadian yeah dude all right well
thank you moving on I mean I'm wearing a
Goku costume yeah dude talking about
pissing my pants um whole couping dude
and one thing I like to do is really I
really save up all that piss brother and
then when I need it I go
I shoot my piss like a you know hadouken
right is that what happens in Dragon
Ball yes that's exactly it okay well
let's uh [__] our pants let's piss yeah
no idea what that's gonna be about some
economists now believe humanity is
approaching a large-scale evolution of
the Global Financial system spurred by
AI assisted investing tools will and
Chad please share your thoughts on the
astonishing future of Finance for
Humanity this is [__] Traders begin
that's pretty interesting
um does it mean is it talking about ding
dong coin yeah dude yeah god dude ding
dong coin dude yeah I don't know what
that is that was well maybe figure it
out because that was wow dude
Canadian
Hulk culture I guess dude up in Northern
Canada Western Northern Canada we got
ding dong coin now dude uh uh this is
what's gonna happen look uh there there
has been a lot of conjecture about this
like what is AI going to do in the
investment world right if you can train
an AI to look at all the movements of
stocks or crypto or whatever you might
be investing in is there going to be an
AI that can be very predictive about it
that can make [__] loads of money with
it and then who gets to control that AI
um and who gets to make the money off of
it that's what people are are kind of
worried about with AI in the financial
world that said I believe the current
Financial system at least in America is
very soon going to shift to a more kind
of um
coverage style system so that no people
actually have money you're just getting
government coverage it's almost like
health insurance and so you'll be on
some tier of coverage
okay
that will all right go on so you'll be
on some tier of coverage that will uh
give you basic minimum coverage or
slightly higher middle class coverage
upper class coverage or you know full
lifestyle coverage if you want to talk
about something like this I think that's
where it's headed that you have no money
you just have what the government gives
you based on whatever your job is that
might contribute to it as well and so I
have a question yeah what the [__] are
you talking about man the future of
Finance just with dudes yes I don't even
understand that's not what dudes he
asked us yeah no it said [__] Traders
right but this [__] Traders is about the
future of finance and how AI factors
into that you know lulio always has to
watch me piss now
okay yeah he's always watching me pee I
take a pee in his cute little face is
over there getting close to the ball
going what are you what are you peeing
so
how are you interpreting what dudes he
asked I don't understand we literally
said that uh Financial experts are
talking about how AI enhanced
Investments are altering the face of
finance and then asked us to predict
what is uh going to be the future of it
and I think that's largely it once
somebody has an AI powerful enough to
make every proper investment that person
is going to have all the money in the
world that tier of people I should say
that class of people and so then what's
going to happen are they going to allow
inflation to just become [__] insane
so a loaf of bread is a million dollars
no they're going to take money out of
the equation and say we're the only
people who have money and we'll give you
a coverage tier we'll give you enough to
get x amount of food per week or month
we'll give you enough to have your rent
in quotes paid under this coverage tier
I think that's what American Finance
will move toward a coverage system no
I'm not saying this as a prediction yeah
but I'm just going to say on the flip
side of that coin we have
um Financial systems around the world
just crumbling everything turns into
Greece exactly what I mean the country
right not the not the uh the the the
thing that comes out of chicken right uh
or that you put on your in your wheels
dude yeah and around the engine brother
might chain dude and that's that
impersonation right there is simply
Robert Loggia
I'll take it yeah well they all have to
take it too because when Chad does an
impersonation it's either Robert Loggia
or Caitlyn Jenner that those are the two
when you do [__] impersonations hate
to say it every once in a while they all
are Randy Newman take it back no sir
take it back that's true actually
someone I've read a com I read a few
comments yeah on the internet that said
that uh last week when I was singing
Under the Bridge by the Red Hot Chili
Peppers that it sounded like Randy
Newman dude it did it did sound like
random it's hard to believe it was
literally
the red hot Newman Peppers yeah
uh Anthony ranthony
Kidman nice dude Anthony Kidman let's do
a little bit of that dudes the after
dudese shirty hey you guys want to see
some uh Randy Newman Red Hot Chili
Peppers karaoke let's get into that
dudes the afternoon sure hey Chad I
think that the term [__] Traders okay
the duty is is using for the segment
yeah with regard to what it's laying out
for us in this segment is about people
just
what if things go revert back the
financial systems everywhere collapse
yeah the internet would not work if
Finance goes down technology follows and
then we are as uh Tyler Durden uh says
in in um well at Norton but Tyler Durden
says in Fight Club in the world I
Envision We Are all uh climbing the
wrist thick Kudzu Vines as they swirl up
the uh the uh what was it the Sears
Tower and uh uh drawing uh pemmican uh
venison over over the sides of what used
to be super highways and you got that
quote down dude yeah dude it's [__]
exact verbatim yeah I don't know I just
I like that movie so
his name is Robert Paulson the thing is
the thing is I don't want this as a
future I want the next 52 years to be uh
smooth just like everyone else I think
the people everywhere certainly in our
country up north in my homeland of of
Canada and across the world toonies dude
loonies dude for [__] sake people just
want to take care of their families and
have a good life but if things go there
then I think we're going to actually be
trading some [__] as I've said before
I'm gonna buy land over an aquifer and
just be the water King then we all know
that I am and uh what if we just end up
trading trading [__] back and forth
trading our things we got a bunch of
let's start with you and I Chad we now
are in possession of a bunch of
wrestling cards tops wrestling cards
we're gonna be trading rookies for water
yeah that's welcome to bada Town
remember that what what's that
Thunderdome Mad Max Thunderdome we don't
need enough another
hero
we don't need to know the way home
all we want is life beyond the
Thunderdome
[Music]
you're good sooner getting better yeah
getting better all the time getting
better
um but in Bordertown they traded literal
pig [__] that was their currency oh
really big [__] yeah well remember that
Tina Turner she was the queen of barter
time yes I do remember that
um Master Blaster dude let me tell you
uh truth is being placed at a premium oh
my God oh my God Chad okay and the truth
about [__] Traders the bottom line if
you boil it if you boil that pig [__]
down yeah it's that human beings uh
and and uh with our brains develop to
the degree that they are at this point
in evolution
we'll be okay
because we'll always be able to trade
we'll always be able to understand the
value of our [__] and that is that is
[__] Traders okay yeah life finds a way
thank you moving on oh really that was
just a big old pile of [__] I don't
know what I'm saying oh
I think I do I knew what I was saying
yeah you you know you know about these
things I'll say that about my pal ciao
you really have uh uh you've dedicated a
lot of thought to uh the future you're a
futurist I'm a humanist
um and uh lulio's been watching me piss
a lot yeah good for him
this concludes the historic 71st episode
of Duty
will and Chad you scored a 97 bringing
your cumulative total to
6759 you only have
3241 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
for next week I would love it if you
both could bring in three pictures that
you take over the course of this next
week just three moments that you found
interesting in some way and we'll do a
little show and tell capiche
yeah that's cool yeah interesting that
sounds kind of fun okay we got some
points too and we're gonna divvy those
out and dudes the after doozy see who's
responsible for what yeah thanks to
everyone for joining us this week we had
fun and we'll have even more next week
until then call me dudesia hey you know
before we move on to dudes after doozy I
want to say rest in peace to the funker
Terry Funk passed away uh last week at
the age of 79 also from Amarillo Texas
how was it yeah member of the funk
family
uh Dory Funk senior his brother Dory
Funk Jr and Terry Funk without Terry
Funk in wrestling a lot of things don't
happen a lot of people say that he's the
first hardcore wrestler uh you can watch
the old Bret Hart documentary wrestling
with shadows and see what Terry Funk did
for the upstart company ECW helped to
put them on the map in their first
pay-per-view without Terry Funk there's
no there arguably there's no ECW there's
there may not be an attitude era in the
WWE and uh uh rest in peace to Terry
Funk and I also want to say as as a huge
wrestling fan and a big wrestling nerd
that uh we had a massive loss last week
very unexpected tragic death of Bray
Wyatt Wyndham rotunda speaking of uh
someone with a lineage although this is
not he's set out on a course of his own
but uh the son of um Mike Rotunda
brother of Bo Dallas the the nephew of
Barry Windham and uh grandson of
Blackjack Mulligan Bray Wyatt was an
artist through and through that man is
an unbelievable Storyteller in the world
of professional wrestling this guy what
he wove into his character of Bray Wyatt
and on through the fiend and the Firefly
fun house era of Bray Wyatt is cannot be
understated please do yourself a favor
nerd out and uh check out some of that
and uh and uh what a loss of an amazing
amazing amazing artist and and that's
exactly what he is uh wrestling at its
best is is art with all sorts of [__]
mixed in and I just want to read
something that Bray Wyatt wrote on
Twitter a while back and uh and uh it's
it's it's interesting hearing hearing it
come from from someone who's writing it
as just Wyndham rotunda not Bray Wyatt
and he says this wrestling is not a love
story it's a fairy tale for masochists a
comedy for people who criticize punch
lines a fantasy most can't understand a
spectacle no one can deny lines are
blurred heroes are villains budgets are
cut business is business
rest in peace Terry Funk and Bray Wyatt
[Music]
follow the buzzards
let me in
yowie wowie welcome to dudesy after
dudes he is the part of the show where
we just cut back and hang out
patreon.com
stuff seven bucks a month gets you this
and everything else if you're watching
on YouTube you can tell the mood's a
little uh it's a little more mellow you
know things have gotten a little uh blue
and and dark in here and uh we're just
gonna chill I'm gonna have some cannabis
dude yeah brother I like to have a
little gain of it sometimes to do the
after doozy brother and sometimes I do
to the gym on a Saturday or maybe late
on a Friday dude but you got hold on
dude hold on Chad hold on dude you got
to make sure that you maybe you have a
safe way to get to and from the gym bro
yeah I like to go with my wonderful wife
Molly and then I'm stacking plates on
that leg press Brother people like hey
can I work in with you I'm like you
couldn't even try dude cause I'm plating
it up I'm stacking them on both sides
dude we're talking 700 we're talking 800
900 pounds dude we're getting to that
half ton brother and we got to do at
least 12 12 to 15 reps dude that's how
you put on them gains dude cannabis
brother all right anyway
welcome to dudesy after doozy the
flagship weekly show of Duty plus I got
a call from the office I have to go in
and put out a few fires but I'll be back
before you know it to Crown the episode
champion this is doozy after dudesy
begin
I'm gonna join you in the cannabis
hey
whoa
I got something to start us off you know
um I met someone uh in the public well
that's the real world dude that's not
look at the size of his pipe this guy in
his pipe uh and they they uh they
approached me it's always nice to meet
people in in uh in the world who enjoy
doozy because it is uh it's something
that we're just doing down here at the
end of the day you know doozy has tasked
us with doozy but we are here in ham
Federal one Studios which happens to be
in the basement of my home it's two
dudes [__] around and then you
wonderful people can hit us up on the
internet and this person came up to me
in real life and asked me a question
about dudesy that I've never been asked
before and that question was
you do
please tell a friend and then write a
review
if you like to see here
[Music]